[A CAPPELLA SINGING]
TV REPORTER: Princeton
University, in Princeton, New
Jersey, today announced the
end of it's all-male
educational tradition.
SUSAN CRAIG SCOTT: They made
the final decision to admit
women to the university, not
just to admit women to the
university, but to do it within
the next eight months.
MARSHA LEVY-WARREN: Arriving on
campus in 1969, there was a
tremendous amount of hubbub.
SUSAN CRAIG SCOTT: And as soon
as we heard that that was what
was going to happen, we among
ourselves decided that we
would apply.
MAE WONG MILLER: When
we arrived on campus
there was no housing.
MARSHA LEVY-WARREN: It felt like
a small group of women on
a male campus.
CAROL BROWN: The university was
ready for co-education but
still adjusting.
MARSHA LEVY-WARREN: Most of the
precepts I was in, I was
usually the only female
in the room.
I say in the room because, of
course, there weren't a lot of
female faculty members, either,
although there were some.
And they were very
important to us.
NANCY MALKIEL: They had systems,
if you will, for
understanding what to do about
spouses who were women, but
the, what do we do if it's a
woman faculty member with a
male spouse, nobody knew how
to reckon with that.
MARSHA LEVY-WARREN: The impetus
was to have a place
for us that felt
defined by us.
It was extremely important to
just meet and talk-- and talk
from the heart--
about what it was like to be
a woman, for it to be 1969,
1970, 1971.
The Vietnam War was about and
feminism was really taking
hold in a different way, and
we wanted to talk about
politics and personal
lives and how we
envisioned our futures.
JUANITA JAMES: So much happened
in a relatively short
period of time from us coming
in as the vanguard to being
involved with every aspect of
the fabric of university life,
and in leadership roles.
CAROL BROWN: We were definitely
a class of women
who were there ready to
take on the world.
The active female athletes were
a mix of what might have
been labeled feminists, but most
of us were just saying,
hey, I want to do this and
there's no reason I shouldn't
be allowed to, and
I'm not going to
take no for an answer.
[POP MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNE CHENG: I think the reason
why my works focus so much on
race and gender and how they
intersect is because not only
do they intersect, they're
very parallel.
You know, this question of, how
does a woman come to find
her own voice and a place in
the world, is to me very
intimately tied into the
question of how you go from
being an immigrant
to a citizen.
think that the difficult thing
is to assimilate, but to do so
in a way that you can still
hold on to who you are.
[POP MUSIC PLAYING]
JESS DEUTSCH: I think that the
male-female ratio was moving
toward more balance while I was
an undergraduate, so as
women I think we felt
we could pretty much
do anything on campus.
We certainly hoped for more
female administrators,
faculty, and coaches as mentors,
but basically, I
think we knew that we belonged
to Princeton and that
Princeton belonged to us.
PATRICE JEAN: For women in the
sciences, especially in the
department of molecular
biology, it was
actually quite fantastic.
There were several very young
established and accomplished
professors, including at the
time Professor Shirley
Tilghman, now President
Tilghman.
JUANITA JAMES: I don't think
I would have imagined as an
undergraduate that in my
lifetime I would live to see a
woman become president of
Princeton University.
MALE SPEAKER: To the
best of my ability.
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN: To the
MALE SPEAKER: So help me, God.
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN:
So help me, God.
NANCY MALKIEL: To have a faculty
member like that so
admired and so well known across
the campus be selected
as president was simply
exhilarating.
And to have it be a woman.
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN: Well, I think
the significance for me
was not as a woman or even
as the first woman
president of Princeton.
I was really focused from the
instant I knew that I was
going to be president, and I'm
trying to be the very best
president I could be.
But I do understand completely
that for many others it had a
deep significance.
We had a long and storied
history in which we were
largely a male institution.
Women had, as you know, had
arrived on campus relatively
recently, given our long
history, and therefore I think
for many there was a
significance to having the
first woman president.
CAROL BROWN: We knew we'd
been picked to lead.
We weren't sure what we were
going to lead or where we were
going to lead, but we were ready
to take on anything.
JUANITA JAMES: I credit my
Princeton experience for
turning me into a leader.
MAE WONG MILLER: Life on an
all-male campus was easier
than going into a male-dominated
work world.
[POP MUSIC PLAYING]
ADDIE MICIR: Princeton is full
of women who are very set in
what they want and their ideas,
and it's great to see
them in leadership positions
all throughout campus.
NORMA LOPEZ CAMPOS: My favorite
thing about Princeton
has been its people.
And yeah, a lot of those people
have been women, and I
don't think I would have stepped
up to the leadership
positions that I have if it
had not been for the past
leaders that came before me.
ADDIE MICIR: The women speak
their mind here on campus, and
it's been a great experience
all around.
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN: I think
Princeton is a place that has
the capacity to empower
students.
We want students to arrive on
this campus already prepared
to be stimulated, to be
challenged, but for me the
most important thing is when
they graduate they feel
empowered, ready to take on
the world, ready to make a
difference in the world.
And I hope that as much for our
women students as I do for
our male students.
We're going to need them all in
the future, and that's what
our job has to be going
forward at Princeton.
[A CAPPELLA SINGING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]